the uk has agreed to withdraw draft
clauses and brexit legislation
that would have broken international law
and reneged on its earlier agreement
with the european union
the move is being hailed as progress by
both britain
and ireland but on the separate matter
of reaching a trade deal
there's still no sign of progress
all right let's uh find out what the
state of play is with these talks i want
to take you now to
dw's brussels bureau chief alexander von
nahman
to find out the latest about the brexit
talks alexander remind viewers please
what these
clauses that we just reported on were
about and why the european union
objected to them in the first place
well to understand that we need to step
back a little bit last year the european
union
and the uk agreed on the terms of their
divorce so to speak
on the withdrawal agreement and one key
point there was to make sure even after
brexit that the
border between the republic of ireland
and northern ireland will
remain an open border that no goods
there will
need to be checked that some of
the use customs rules will remain in
place but then the uk said oh we don't
know how it's going to be implemented
maybe it's going to hurt us when we
don't have a trade agreement with the
european union
so they went on and those closes
on potential tariffs on customs rules
customs declarations and state
they were meant to enable the government
in london to overrule this agreement
with the european union so of course the
european union was infuriated
and now the uk is saying okay we're
taking that back and
going back to what actually was agreed
last year
all right so how much of a concession is
this by the british government to the eu
and does this mean a brexit deal can
still be salvaged
well the honest answer to that is maybe
it's definitely a positive
sign a gesture of good will and it can
help
improve the atmosphere in the actual
talks between the ua
the eu and uk on the possible trade
agreement it can help
restore trust but we are hearing from
politicians in the european parliament
that they are
not sure about that that damage has been
done that they don't know if they can
trust
the uk and their government and
of course some voices here are also
saying that it could be an excuse for
boris johnson to say okay
we now showed this uh gesture of
goodwill and if the eu
is not ready to compromise that we can
just walk away so i would say that
it can go both ways still
can go both ways dw brussels bureau
chief alexander vanaman reporting
thank you now the two sides need to come
to an agreement before
january 1st otherwise from that day
onward
tariffs will have to be paid on goods
entering the uk from the eu
and the other way around so what's at
stake well the world trade organization
puts the figure at 3.1 percent for
customs tariffs for goods from the eu to
the uk
and 3.3 percent for goods heading the
other way
that's not all certain types of products
could even have much higher duty
much higher duties rather come the new
year cars in agriculture could see
tariffs as high as 13 while products
like milk
could even see something as whopping as
36 percent
now with the economies on both sides of
the channel suffering due to the corona
virus
crisis neither wants brexit to happen
without a deal in place
now i'm joined now by ulrich ackermann
he's head of foreign trade for germany's
vdma mechanical engineering association
hello mr ackermann thank you for joining
us hello
i wanted to ask you um how are your
members approaching this moment right
now as the negotiations near
yeah the member companies have to adapt
to a hard brexit or to a smooth brexit
that means they have to adapt their
international i.t processes
they have to prepare the relevant custom
documents
and if a hard brexit comes they have to
pay custom duties
but what is open now is how will
the impact of the border controls be
on the delivery times for example and
what is the availability of trucks
and containers on both sides so we have
a lot of questions open now
what kind of costs are you seeing put on
your members as they just prepare for
either outcome yeah i have recently had
a
a conversation with a medium-sized
mechanical engineering company and they
explained to me
that only the customs declarations cost
for them as a medium-sized companies
is around 280 000 euro and also this
company has to
increase its stocks in the uk for
finished products and for spare parts
which is binding several millions of
euro in capital
are those tariffs that could come about
in the event of a no trade deal are
those going to make or break any of the
businesses that are part of your
membership no i don't think so because
terrorists in machinery sector on both
sides are relatively low
for example on the u side terrorist in
the machinery sector is 1.5
to 3 percent which is not a not a very
high figure
so we will not have any significant
effect about this
are there other concerns facing your
members if not the tariffs themselves or
their other concerns aside from customs
in terms of standards are obviously one
issue that are facing both sides how
does that affect your industry
yeah now we have standards all over
europe
and the after states that means we have
a machinery directive and
safety standards for all kinds of
machines and it's still open
what will happen with the uk they want
to have control back
that means they in the middle medium
term they want to
develop their own standards and this was
in the business with the united kingdom
and then lastly do you see any benefits
to brexit from your side at all or is it
all just
pitfalls for your businesses no we see
no benefits
at the end it's a lose-lose result for
the europeans and also for great britain
because a business is difficult
after the brexit than it was before all
right orrish ackerman with the vdma
thank you very much for joining us
okay thank you very much bye
and let's bring in now our financial
correspondent in frankfurt chelsea
delaney
chelsea good to see you um we talk about
the uncertainty that businesses must
prepare for and the costs that come with
that
how does that weigh on markets are we
seeing it there
we have seen a little bit of pressure on
markets both in the uk
and in europe over the past couple of
days as the hopes for a trade deal
dim a little bit we've heard today for
example from prime minister boris
johnson in the uk that
really people should not be getting
their hopes up about a deal at this
point
but of course i would say markets are
really underpricing the risks of a no
deal brexit
many investors remain quite optimistic
that the
the the logic will prevail the economic
consequences will drive
these leaders to reach a deal but i
would say that investors are really not
prepared at this point
for a no deal brexit all right chelsea
delaney watching markets in frankfurt
thank you